welcome everybody to marry kill today we
have the lovely Ariel who is married to
one of the men on the other side of this
curtain the other two men are his
friends and she's going to have to
figure out which one of them is her
husband so she can take him to marry and
then pick one of the others too and kill
are you ready I feel it pretty good
right because you don't want to ruin
your relationship yeah yeah yeah I'm
Ariel and today I'm going to marry my
husband or at least him but I'm
definitely not gonna kill him
I know this isn't how the game works but
I hope that she both marries and but you
know the way Meg talks about being
married it just sounds great
I want that I'm gonna marry dead twice I
want Ariel to choose Ned to get married
because that's true love but it doesn't
mean she still came for me yeah I just
don't want to die so why don't we go
ahead and start the game where you have
a question that you're gonna ask all
three people so go ahead and read this
question after them take a look at it
for everyone I am a girl with a strong
relationship with my parents what is the
one thing you would never want my
parents to find out about you and we'll
start with mr. one well sometimes I get
a little excited about things I can
overreact but you know I've always been
very good around people's parents after
hearing that answer how do you feel
about mr. Warren generally a nice guy
great all right mr. to same question I
would maybe just keep some of the
details of date night product
okay so this is a very private person
nice mister three go ahead and answer
that same question what do you not want
her parents to know about you okay so
you've heard from all three of our mr.
numbers right now which one of these
numbers do you think you want to kill
number three sounds like like somebody
out of like evil out of The Hobbit so
I'm just gonna say that okay but
definitely not my final answer I have no
answer great let's go ahead and move on
to round two we're gonna ask each person
an individual question mister - I think
that space is the true final destination
if you were a planet what type of
species would it have it you and why
well if I were a planet I would be your
anus mr11
i am an equestrian at heart what is the
heat cutest outfit a horse could wear
and why I think I would have a really
cute girl horse and she would be
a nice little bike if these poodle skirt
like the cute little dress and have like
really high ponytail does that sound
like somebody you'd wanna pop mister
three I'm a vegetarian so I don't eat
any meat but if you were a cannibal
which celeb would you want to eat first
no it's so wet but you want to eat first
[Music]
we're gonna move on to the final round
this last question is for all three of
them okay tell me a haiku about how
great I am
let's actually start with mister three
this time let's move to mr. two is date
night cuddling and snuggling oh all
right please don't kill me mister one
what's your haiku you design so well
will you decorate my house are you done
okay okay so we've heard the haikus
we've heard all these questions now
ariel is the time to decide who are you
going to who are you gonna marry and who
you're gonna kill blocking your choices
and we're going to reveal your decisions
to you one by one you have chosen good
I'm sorry I can't right now but we need
to go pay our respects to the recently
deceased I know I know well you did this
you killed him go ahead and see who
you've done away with would you like to
say it's like I'm really sorry but we
all knew that but you know what that
means do you Ariel take Ned to be your
husband
even though you just do Jean and it was
good you know what I'm saying it was
good
do you still want this you still want
this I mean I all right then you may
kiss your husband again yeah
[Applause]
beautiful thanks so much for playing but
we'll see you next time on Mary how was
that sex though ah sex I yeah I don't
wanna keep kids but